pour ce premier jour des vacances
scolaires on vous propose une idée de
sortie en famille direction le château
de Langeais qui participe cette année
encore à l'opération Noël au pays des
châteaux le monument a décidé de mettre
l'accent sur les illuminations de Noël
bougie lanterne et guirlandes donne une
atmosphère particulière au lieu les la
Turquie
un Noël tout en lumière plongé dans
l'obscurité le château de Langeais est
paré de ses plus belles décorations
lumineuses et éclaire les yeux des plus
petits comme des plus grands c'est très
très bien j'adore je visiter le château
avec
[Musique]
très très bien trop beau
merveilleux des éclairages le sapin
décoré et on a vraiment l'impression que
le château est vivant il est habité et
c'est vraiment très agréable de s'y
promener plusieurs centaines de bougies
parsemées au fil des pièces pour
découvrir le château sous un tout nouvel
angle c'est la sixième édition de Noël
au pays des châteaux et ici allongé
chaque hiver c'est la lumière qui est
mise à l'honneur avec des salles
éclairées presque comme au 15ème siècle
on a réinterprété cette cette lumière à
travers bien évidemment des bougies mais
aussi des lanternes des guirlandes alors
un château à Noël c'est un château où on
voit ses collections
vivre son histoire et on le voit décorer
comme il aurait peut-être pu l'être au
Moyen-Âge des décors à découvrir en
complément des collections permanentes
et ce jusqu'au 2 janvier 203